Well having only 1 thread issuing memory transactions certainly limits
the number of bytes delivered and that's our total achieved bandwidth.
Version 2 with a single thread per a row still will only have a single thread block running on
a single SM issuing transactions, and again
this is not going to be enough to fill this big fat pipe.
Version 3 had plenty of parallelism and plenty of transactions and flights.
The problem there was the uncoalesced right ack operations limited our useful bytes delivered.
And our current version of the code, which uses shared memory to achieve
better coalescing among the threads and get higher numbers
of useful bytes delivered for every transaction,
still uses 1 thread per element, and therefore is achieving plenty of transactions to fill the pipeline.
So where does that leave us? We're still achieving lower bandwidth than we would have expected.
And we know that we're delivering plenty of useful bytes per transaction.
So, the problem really must be the average latency.
There must be something that's keeping the time between transactions
higher than it should be to fill this pipeline.